>> >> Laura: THIS WAS PART OF E
DEMOCRATS OFFICIAL RESPONSE
DELIVERED BY CONGRESSMAN JOE
KENNEDY TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS PLAN FIVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSES TO THE PRESIDENT’S
ADDRESS, WHY STOP AT FIVE?
SOUNDS LIKE A REAL UNIFIED PARTY
TO ME.
THEY COULDN’T PICK JUST ONE?
THEY HAD TO GO TO FIVE PEOPLE.
THAT IS VERY DIVERSE.
THAT INCLUDES A SPEECH BY
BERNIE SANDERS TONIGHT, THAT IS
THE ONE I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
AN MAXINE WATERS TOMORROW.
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS TONIGHT.
IF YOU HAVE THAT MANY MESSAGES
DO YOU REALLY HAVE A MESSAGE AT
ALL?
LET’S GO BACK TO OUR PANEL.
PHILIPPE, DOES THIS PARTY HAVE A
UNIFIED RESPONSE TO
DONALD TRUMP?
OBVIOUSLY, HE HAS UNIFIED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT’S INTERESTING TO LOOK BACK A
YEAR, YEAR AND A HALF AGO, HE’S
THE MOST DIVISIVE REPUBLICAN, HE
IS RIPPING THE PARTY TO SHREDS!
I LOVE LOOKING BACK ON THOSE
SOUND BITES FROM SOME OF OUR
FRIENDS ON THE OTHER CABLE
CHANNELS.
HE’S UNIFIED THE PARTY UNLIKE
ANYONE I HAVE SEEN SINCE RIGHT
AFTER 2001 OR MAY BE REAGAN.
>> TAX CUTS WILL DO THAT.
I DO WANT TO TAKE ISSUE WITH
YOUR NUMBERS.
YOU SAID THERE WERE FIVE
DEMOCRATS?
I THINK THERE ARE FOUR.
I WON’T COUNT FOR ANY AS AN ACTL
DEMOCRAT.
>> Laura: FAIR POINT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THAT.
>> Laura: I WILL GIVE YOU THAT
THAT.
>> PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
MESSAGES.
TEN PEOPLE CAN TALK AND NO ONE’S
GOING TO GET THE ATTENTION THE
PRESIDENT DOES ON THE NIGHT OF
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
IT LETS YOU --
>> Laura: THAT WAS
EMBARRASSING.
REMEMBER WHEN BOBBY JINDAL
SASHAYED OUT?
THAT WEIRD WALK?
>> PEOPLE WILL BE TALKING MORE
ABOUT THAT --
>> Laura: HE WAS SWEATING A
LOT.
THIS FACT WAS HARD.
NIXON AND KENNEDY -- THIS CASE,
IT WAS KENNEDY’S WEDDING.
>> IT’S REPUBLICANS SING IT, NOT
ME.
>> FOR DEMOCRATS TO TRY OUT A
YOUNG, NEW, FRESH FACE.
HOW OLD IS HE?
>> WHAT HIS NAME IS JOE KENNEDY!
THAT IS THEIR FRESH FACE?
>> Laura: DYNASTIES AREN’T A
GOOD THING.
THEY WANT TO ATTACK THE CLICK
BUSHES.
KAMALA HARRIS?
I WOULD PUT HER OUT THERE.
I THINK SHE’S INTERESTING.
SHE’S AN INTERESTING PERSON.
JOE KENNEDY, HE LOOKED LIKE HE
WANTED TOO MANY TONY ROBBINS
SEMINARS.
A LOT OF STRESSES ON THE WRONG
WORDS AND IT’S HARD BECAUSE TO
FOLLOW TRUMP, IT’S REALLY HARD.
>> WHAT WAS THE BROKEN DOWN CAR
IN THE BACKGROUND?
>> Laura: UNCLEAR.
BECAUSE FALL RIVER IS KNOWN FOR
ITS BROKEN DOWN MILLS.
>> MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE HAD A
SUPER BOWL PATRIOTS SIGN BACK
THERE.
>> Laura: BYRON, IT’S NOT
FAIR.
WE’VE TALKED ABOUT -- I KNOW YOU
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT POOR
RICKY RUBIO, BOBBY JINDAL, IT
NEVER WORKS.
SO I THINK WE SHOULD JUST
DISPENSE OF THEM ALTOGETHER.
HAVE SOME OTHER TYPE OF EVENT.
>> WELL, YOU CAN’T WIN, AND THE
DEMOCRATS GOT INTO A MIC
TONIGHT.
BUT WHAT THEY DO DO DOES TELL US
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
THEY ARE REALLY DEEPLY DIVIDED,
IT APPEARS TO BE, AND INTEREST
GROUPS, THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
RESPONSES, BASICALLY RANGING
FROM A CENTER LEFT TO THE FAR
LEFT.
THAT WAS ALL THROUGHOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESENCE.
I SAW A TWEET TONIGHT ABOUT
REPRESENTATIVE GUTIERREZ, THE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN, WHO WAS
WEARING THREE DIFFERENT ITEMS OF
CLOTHING TO INDICATE --
>> Laura: WHAT WAS THAT?
>> HE HAD A TIME’S UP PIN FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, HE HAD A
BUTTERFLY PIN FOR THE DREAMERS,
AND HE WAS WEARING AN AFRICAN
CLOTH TO PROTEST DONALD TRUMP’S
"S-HOLE" COMMENTS.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
SOME TYPE OF --
>> I’M NOT EXPECTED TO DEFEND
THAT.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT A WALKING
BILLBOARD.
THERE WAS A JOY TO READ TWEET,
JUST FOR THE HECK OF IT, IT’S
PAST MIDNIGHT, SHE TWEETED
TONIGHT.
THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
"CHURCH, FAMILY, POLICE,
MILITARY, THE NATIONAL ANTHEM,
TROPES OF 1950s ERA
NATIONALISM.
THE GOAL OF THIS SPEECH APPEARS
TO FORCE THE NORMALIZATION OF
TRUMP ON THE TERMS OF THE BYGONE
ERA HIS SUPPORTERS ARE NOSTALGIC
FOR."
PHILIPPE, DOES THAT SOME OF THE
PARTY THAT WE ARE ALL UPSET WHEN
CHURCH, FAMILY, MILITARY, THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM GETS MENTIONED?
>> IT WAS A VERY TRADITIONAL
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS AND I
THINK THAT’S A PROBLEM BECAUSE
HE’S NOT A TRADITIONAL
PRESIDENT --
>> Laura: YOU’VE MADE THAT
POINT.
TALK ABOUT YOUR PARTY.
TO THE PEOPLE WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE.
I THINK THE POINT OF WHAT HE
DIDN’T SAY IS IMPORTANT.
COREY WAS MENTIONING AND YOU
WERE SAYING THAT HE PUT AMERICA
FIRST FIRST.
I THINK HE PUT THE THREATS WE
FACED LAST OR NOT AT ALL.
AND EVERYONE WILL JUMP ON ME THE
MINUTE I SAY RUSSIA BUT LET’S
FORGET ABOUT THE MEMO AND ALL
THAT.
GREG POMPEO, PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
CIA DIRECTOR, SAID RUSSIANS ARE
GOING --
>> Laura: MIKE.
>> SORRY, MIKE POMPEO.
[LAUGHS]
MIKE POMPEO IS GOING TO SCREW
WITH US.
RUSSIA WILL SCREW WITH US IN
NOVEMBER, 2018.
THIS IS THE POSITION OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
WHY DOES THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES NOT SAY THAT WE
WILL NOT TOLERATE THAT?
IF IRAN WERE GOING TO SCREW
AROUND, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
THE SPEECH.
IF NORTH KOREA, IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THE SPEECH.
>> Laura: THAT’S A FAIR POINT
I THINK.
I MIGHT HAVE THROWN THAT IN
THERE.
MY QUESTION, I DON’T REMEMBER, I
MIGHT BE WRONG, DID BARACK OBAMA
REFERENCE THE 50 MILLION
PERSONNEL FILES THAT CHINA STOLE
FROM THE OFFICE OF PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT AMONG THE MIND AND
MANY OTHERS?
AND THEIR CYBER SPYING?
STEALING OF SUPERCOMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY?
THE STEALING OF THE INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY?
CHALLENGING US AT EVERY LEVEL?
RUSSIA’S ECONOMY IS SMALLER THAN
THE SIZE OF FRANCE.
CHINA HAS A LARGER STANDING ARMY
THAN OURS RIGHT NOW.
I DON’T -- CHINA THREATENS US AT
EVERY TURN, ALL AROUND THE WORLD
ALL THE TIME.
>> WHY DOES RUSSIA NOT GET --
>> Laura: YOU WERE OBSESSING
ON IT BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCE.
>> I DON’T LIKE RUSSIANS
THINKING TO MAKE IT SCREW AROUND
>> Laura: I DON’T RECALL YOUR
PARTY ABSCESS WITH THE
SOVIET UNION WHEN THEY WERE THE
SOVIET UNION.
THIS IS DETENTE TO CENTRAL.
NOW IT IS "RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA?
."
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
WHY THE ECONOMY IS DOING WELL,
LICHEN, CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS
UP, AND WHITE AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM HAS BEEN BEATEN
DOWN, FRANKLY, FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS.
>> WHY DOES THAT EXCLUDE
PROTECTING US FROM --
>> Laura: I DON’T THINK HE IS.
>> BY NOT SAY IT?
>> Laura: IF HE SAID IT, YOU’D
BE ONTO THE NEXT THING.
>> I WOULDN’T COME ACTUALLY.
>> Laura: EVERY TIME THE
DEMOCRATS SAY RUSSIA, I SAY
CHINA, AND THEY NEVER HAD OF AN
ANSWER --
>> WE CAN HANDLE --
>> Laura: BUT OBAMA NEVER
DEAD.
HE NEVER FOCUSED ON CHINA.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE DID HAVE EIGHT YEARS OF A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT WHO GOT
KIND OF RUN OVER PRETTY BADLY BY
THE DEMOCRATS -- I MEAN, BY THE
RUSSIANS, INCLUDING THE RESET
EFFORT, WHICH FAILED, AND
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
EVERYTHING THAT DID HAPPEN
UNDER --
>> WE NEVER TALKED ABOUT
URANIUM ONE WHEN BARACK OBAMA
WAS IN OFFICE.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT IT.
>> AMERICA, TAX CUTS, JOBS,
UNEMPLOYMENT, SECURITY FOR
PEOPLE, INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING,
GOD, AND YOUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS WITH THE STATE OF THE
UNION IS ABOUT.
IT’S ABOUT MAKING PEOPLE PROUD
TO BE AMERICANS AGAIN.
>> Laura: I THINK IT’S NOT
EASY --
>> TOUTING 97% OF YOUR PARTY
HAVE BECOME AND 40% OF THE
OPPOSING PARTY NOT, I DON’T SEE
WITH THE RARA IS ABOUT.
>> Laura: OBAMA HIT IT OUT OF
THE PARK ON HIS FIRST, I REALLY
THINK HE DID A GREAT JOB IN HIS
FIRST SPEECH.
IT’S NOT LIKE I WILL LIKE IT IS
A REPUBLICAN BUT IT’S NOT EASY
IN THE COUNTRY IS DOING REALLY
WELL, TRUMP HAS PROBLEMS TO DEAL
WITH AND HE’S GOT TO DEAL WITH
THEM, THE INVESTIGATION IS AN
ALBATROSS, NO DOUBT.
IS NOT EASY TO BE THE PARTY OUT
OF POWER.
WE’LL SEE FOR HOW LONG YOU ARE
OUT OF POWER.
>> I’M NOT SURE THOUGH THAT
PERFORMANCE WILL HELP MUCH IN